a morning walk is a non-negotiable as
soon as I'm up I'm making a beeline for
daylight or as close to Daylight as
sunlight as I can get no caffeine for
the first 90 minutes salt in water so I
use element which is just tastes
fantastic your adrenal system is what's
active for the first 90 minutes of the
day your adenosine system that caffeine
acts on isn't having a morning coffee is
literally pointless you just destroy you
in the afternoon correct that walk get
back breath work state app which is 1.50
a month it's really great it programs in
Progressive overload really really
Fantastic Four Pathways super simple
then meditate if I'm doing guided I'm
using waking up by Sam Harris if I'm
doing unguided I use insight timer which
is just like a meditation timer and I'll
read for about 10 to 15 minutes and this
is usually the same unless I'm traveling
or or I've got different stuff